paris mystérieux les secrets de paris
paraît inépuisable on a dit beaucoup de
choses à ce sujet pourtant louis doucet
vient une nouvelle fois de découvrir
quelque chose d'original dans les rues
de paris cela se passe du côté de
belleville il s'agit d'arbalétriers des
archers de belleville c'est une seule
ont tort des mystères de paris qui
seraient ravis car des mystères varie
pas des cachotteries de vrai mystère il
y en a encore quelques-uns ainsi au fond
d'une impasse
les archers du 20e du 20e arrondissement
s'entend car pour ce qui est du siècle
cela c'est une autre histoire
messieurs je vous salue c
nous sommes organisés en compagnie comme
sous-louer 11
nous avons conservé les mêmes traditions
et nous avons un connétable un roi un
capitaine et des lieutenants et des
chevaliers de bien entendu mais tout ça
semble encore qu'est aujourd'hui
pourquoi au xxème siècle dans le 20e à
roubaix soir au complet au contraire moi
je pense qu'il est il est simple
conserver ses traditions de conserver
une certaine courtoisie 1 3 jantes
conserver les règles de chevalerie on a
l'impression que vous jouez un petit peu
à robin des bois ou si c'est un peu vrai
héros maritime tél oui on arrive au tir
à l'arc par là et puis ensuite on se
transporte mon bien sportif
et puis ensuite on applique les règles
de chevalerie et on les conserve pour la
vie courante
3 parce qu'on peut en conserver alors la
voyez vous avez l'arbalète
or la valette naturellement est un petit
peu plus moderne que l'art que mais on
peut considérer que en temps de guerre
ce n'est pas assez disons rapide pour
armer une flèche il faut absolument
tirer sa maintenir et ainsi de suite
alors qu'avec un arc c'est beaucoup plus
rapides au point de vue disons armements
vous avez la flèche au champ de bataille
ce plus rapidement beaucoup plus enfin
moi mon idée personnelle qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire pour déduire chevallier il
faut de faire une demande d'admission
vous avez des traditions ses traditions
secret est très pratique on ne doit pas
divulguer d'ailleurs on fait jurer à
celui que l'on soit de ne jamais dire à
ses plus proches ce qui l'a vue il nie
entendu lorsqu'un chevalier décèdent de
chevalier d'arc décembre dans la tombe
et sont censé récupérer le secret du
lle autre voie il enfoncer un clou en
travers du cercueil pour s'assurer que
le chevalier était bien mort
hélas pour le folk blanc
au fond de leur réserve les archers de
belleville sont aujourd'hui menacés par
des flèches d'un type qu'il n'avait pas
prévu